welcome back to the David packman show I
am Farren cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today and if you
happen to like me you can go subscribe
to my YouTube channels youtube.com the
ring of fire and youtube.com
fahrenbalanced now let's move on here I
gotta talk about Jim Jordan right
chairman of the house Judiciary
Committee Jim Jordan has uh well he's
really stepped in it I mean he's already
in over his head he's got these
weaponization hearings that even Fox
News has said have been a complete dud
Essie Waters asked couple weeks ago
where are the Bombshells you've been
having these hearings not just Jim
Jordan but the other Republicans you've
given us nothing
but Jim Jordan is hell-bent on making
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
pay for taking on Donald Trump so this
week
Jim Jordan announced that he and his
Judiciary Committee they're going to
take a little field trip up to New York
City on April 17th
and while they're on their little field
trip they're going to hold what they're
calling a field hearing to talk about
the absolutely out of control crime rate
in Manhattan and they're gonna of course
try to tell us that Alvin Bragg instead
of taking on the former president needs
to be taking on all these all these darn
shoplifters out here and the muggers and
the the spray painting vandals that's
the real crime in New York City not this
fraudulent business transaction for a
multi-billion dollar Corporation no no
no no no we don't worry about that Alvin
you need to go get the guy trying to
steal Tylenol from Rite Aid as Eric
Trump pointed out about a week ago
so Jim Jordan heading to New York to
tell us how bad crime really is but uh
here's the thing after this was
announced Alvin Bragg's office issued a
statement
that said if chairman Jordan truly cared
about Public Safety he could take a
short drive to Columbus Dayton
Cincinnati Cleveland Akron or Toledo in
his home state instead of using taxpayer
dollars to travel hundreds of miles
this way
now
the reason
that this Aid to Alvin Bragg released
this statement saying hey if you want to
look at crime go look at your home state
go look in your backyard is because as
Business Insider pointed out Columbus
Ohio which has a population of
approximately 907 000 people closed out
with 15.4 murders per 100
000 citizens
15.4 murders per 100 000 citizens
New York City on the other hand closed
out 2022 with a murder rate of 5.2
murders per 100 000 citizens now correct
me if I'm wrong but wouldn't that mean
that writing Jim Jordan's backyard the
murder rate is almost three times
the murder rate of New York City
now yeah I mean that that kind of seems
like what that means so Jim Jordan as
Alvin Bragg's office said you you want
to talk about the murder rate you want
to talk about people getting killed out
of control crime
all you have to do is go home
why don't you worry about your own
backyard and not about New York City
now the crime rate
in New York and of course in California
we have heard Republicans talk about
that ad nauseam uh for for over a year
really it was a big big thing in the
lead up to the 2022 midterms then then
they stopped talking about it after the
midterms because I guess crime doesn't
exist once elections are over but now
that Alvin Bragg is Prosecuting Donald
Trump we have had Republicans across the
board not just in Congress I know my
Governor down here in Florida Ron
DeSantis while trashing Alvin Bragg
brought up the crime rate there so y'all
want to talk about crime rates let's
talk about crime rates let's talk about
the fact that in New York City
it is true that property crime has
increased
property crime of course being vandalism
theft burglary things like that
however the murder rate
the violent crime rate that includes
non-murders but other violent crime
assaults
um of multiple kinds has decreased
now let's take a look at my state of
Florida down here
now in Florida property crime has gone
down in the last few years
so we're not seeing as many burglaries
and muggings and you know vandalism as
they are in New York City
but what has increased by double digits
down here in the State of Florida is the
violent crime rape a rate excuse me so
here in Florida
you're less likely
to have somebody break into your home
and steal your stuff than New York City
but you're more likely to be killed
or beaten to a pulp or maybe sexually
assaulted
but you don't ever hear the media
talking about that do you no what do
they talk about they talk about the
runaway crime rate in New York City in
the blue States why got news for you
media
the highest crime rates in the country
most of them out of the top 25
take place all down here in the south
was the South have in common folks yeah
we're all red States down here the
highest crime rates in the country are
taking place in red States run with an
iron fist by Republicans
but Republicans don't ever mention that
and the media does such a poor job of
pushing back on these narratives that
blue states are out of control with
crime
that they miss the fact that you're more
likely to be the victim of a crime in a
red State than you are in a blue state
and that's why I love that Bragg's
office has pushed back on Jim Jordan
they've pushed back on him repeatedly
but this is a big one the murder rate in
Jim Jordan's own District
is far higher than it is in New York
City but Jim Jordan is going to waste
our tax dollars he's going to waste
everybody's time going to New York I
what trying to find victims of violent
crime are you hoping to roam the streets
like a vigilante you know maybe you're
gonna pull a Batman and beat up somebody
trying to take a woman's purse from the
street I don't know what Jim Jordan's
gonna do
but I do know that based on everything
we've seen Jim Jordan do this year
it's probably gonna backfire and make
him look like a total idiot
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fumes success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below